you know what I think is [ __ ] weird
and this is not a genius observation by
any means but I think it's really weird
how many rappers keep trying to hang out
with hype house kids that [ __ ] is so
creepy to me like what do you mean like
who like Tiger did that [ __ ] [ __ ] and
yell the hive house kids in his studio
and they're all like doing a dance and
really yeah have you tiger like he
created tick-tock and he was you know
he's really pumping that [ __ ] up I stink
there's something weird about that you
know or even like even the like the
angle of we need to get this big on
tick-tock it's like it's old it's mostly
teenagers that's [ __ ] creepy yeah
unless your music like really appeals
the problem is hip-hop is like the
biggest genre on earth and so most of
the [ __ ] that teens listen to is hip-hop
so well you know I know the most people
mean that in the context of like oh hey
let's come up with a dance and let's
give people dancing to it that you know
totally but I think it's just a bit
weird when they're like collabing with
these people or like we'll mosey filmed
his music video there did you see that
no what yeah his blueberry Faygo music
video you know it's a hit
it's a [ __ ] hit you can film whatever
[ __ ] video you want and people will
watch it yeah and they filmed it at the
hype house and all the kids are in it
I'm playing this with no volume on the
on the screen share okay here blueberry
Faygo I'm surprised that they got the
clearance for the Faygo logo so this so
right right this is wait hold on that's
the high post that's Alex Warren right
there oh no that's look that's the high
house and we just keep watching keep
watching look at that that's the [ __ ]
bathroom that's right here there's a
bunch of scenes of them like doing
dances alone in that bathroom just cut
in out of here I'm out of here and I'm
out of here
kid Laroy this [ __ ] is just
so man it's just like a weird it's like
to me there's like a bro what there's
like a pretty clear divide between the
people that make them I don't know you
know I don't know I'm sorry I'm just a
little thrown off because I just seen
that ass shaking and I don't know if
that was a adolescent ass or or a legal
adult ass probably legal adult ass I
would hope I think it's a legal ass dude
I think it's a legal ass my ass is
illegal when the government starts
tracking us they're gonna see if we look
at you know like I would I would have
gone to jail right there for just
looking at that video yeah but I'm just
saying I'm just saying my ass personally
I'm like of age but my ass is illegal
okay so [ __ ] sick
what were you saying you're like there's
a clear divide between like people that
make the music yeah like that people
that make great music right cuz it's a
really hard thing to do and then the
people that like dance to it on tik-tok
oh yeah yeah cuz I just feel like the
barrier to entry is much less it's
easier to do that it's an easier thing
to like get get poppin doing yeah but
this is just like I feel like little
mozi is I don't know I did it just makes
the music feel cheap
oh yeah 100% no I mean granny Moses
younger so I think it's a it like it it
makes more sense if there was any
artists to do that
I think mozi is the one because he is
well what the [ __ ] how old is he like
barely eighteen oh [ __ ] he's 18 yeah
yeah yeah yeah I thought he was like 24
no no
kidding ya he's a kid so his demo never
mind
yeah wrong no I'm wrong right that's my
kid Laroy is doing the song about it
right - yeah because they're all in that
age like they that makes sense for them
this in my mind it was like okay the
biggest dancer is Charlie D'Amelio and
she's what 15 and so they're all 15 and
rappers are all like 24 but I'm just
[ __ ] wrong ya know I thought I thought
as Andrade was like 15 and someone
corrected me and they're like no she's
20 I was like what yeah yeah so you know
it makes sense but still I still agree
with that it feels cheap like trying to
shoehorn [ __ ] so it's like a gross
like you know it's like dance - this kid
is YouTube jamming the celebrities down
our throat it's the exact same thing
yeah it's like it's like musicians now
trying to jam these [ __ ] just dances
and - do it do it
I hate dance I hate all the corporate
[ __ ] in the background where they're
trying to like cross over all these
things and to just you know we've we use
this we use that and then we can you
know really energize this audience and
bring them together and blue it's like
it's none of that man you're just
[ __ ] just for some people to like it
it works I think that's what's
frustrating me sometimes sometimes it
does most the time it doesn't and either
way I think the whole [ __ ] I'll be
curious to see if any of this hype house
[ __ ] last into next year there probably
will I mean it already they already
broke up dude oh yeah so funny man like
my first or even when we first talked
about it it was like what it was a
couple weeks ago or whatever all the
comments were like I can't wait to see
all the you know all the videos like why
we broke up why I left the house I
palace blah blah blah and it happened
like two weeks later you know what uh is
it everyone is out of there I have no
idea okay
I don't know is the hype house breaking
up yeah they're splitting up
they're also sad day dude
sad day oh man oh man you know what what
dude the guy who fought KS eyes brother
spoke on it as well in Hollywood you say
about it let's see what no I'm not even
gonna give it who gives a [ __ ] gives
that absolute [ __ ] what he had to say
let's watch something dude
you